we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors blinkist is the app that helps
you become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman what a week it has been in
the united states
and uh i'm going to try to put together
some overarching thoughts about what
we've seen in the country
over the last week and by what we've
seen i i of course am talking about
what is really a predictable and logical
culmination
of the most depraved and disgusting
presidential term that we have ever seen
i mean donald trump inciting a riotous
insurrection in washington dc uh when he
simply could not admit that he simply
lost to joe biden he wishes he could
have won but he didn't and
unable to do that it led to what we saw
last week and causing that to splinter
the republican party
part of which has immediately abandoned
donald trump far too late to actually
deserve any rehabilitation of their
reputation
um but it is merely a move for
self-preservation
part of which uh that republican party
continues to defend donald trump
while the country fights a global
hundred-year pandemic that has been
completely mishandled
and seems unable to get the mass
vaccination program growing so
going so that's that's like the big
picture and
we have to be able to say something
overarching about what's going on here
and there are a few lessons in the midst
of the chaos but the most
important thing we can do
is to not understate the importance of
this moment as an inflection point
in the path of the united states of
america
and it's impossible to include
everything that's happened
and i know that many of us are are are
still sort of struggling to figure out
all of the answers about what happened
and there are so many details different
people finding more interesting or less
interesting
and focusing on but there will be
continued time for that
i think understanding the big picture
here and the importance of this moment
is the best thing that we can do
and it really goes back to 2016 when we
had tons of republicans most of the
right
saying we like trump much of the right
saying
well we don't love trump but we still
think he's way better than hillary
and we also had too many of our fellow
leftists saying
trump wouldn't be that bad or he might
even be
sort of like hillary i don't like either
so i won't vote
they're both corporate shills i don't
see any practical difference between the
two
or let's mix it up by putting in trump
it'll be wacky and it'll get us a real
progressive in 2020.
oh the supreme court's not that
important you remember that stuff
those people were all wrong the ones on
the right were obviously wrong and the
ones on the left were obviously wrong as
well now
we don't need apologies let's just
recognize
that they were wrong the people on the
left who were
sounding the alarm as we saw trump's
authoritarian tendencies
and and immediate we saw them before and
immediately after getting elected and
some of us were called hyperbolic and
over exaggerated
if anything we understated the risk
every
worst instinct of donald trump's has
become
the nightmare scenario and it culminated
last week and it might not even be the
culmination we'll talk about
what the next week and a half is going
to look like and it looks like it will
be utterly insane
i'll tell you what donald trump has
planned there will be more armed riots i
am sure of it
how successful they are remains to be
seen so this is all to say
let's not sell short the importance of
this moment and there are two ways that
this moment could go
big picture one way is very
straightforward
we all decide that this can never happen
again
and that putting politics aside putting
aside your view of like
tax rates putting aside your view of
business regulation
we decide as a country that what
happened last week is an existential
threat to the united states
we recognize that joe biden will be
president and that we have to go back to
drawing a line in the sand and saying
all of this from the last four years is
over the line of what is acceptable
period
no matter what your view is on taxation
right
and part of this is i i have to say
not tolerating trumpian insanity it's
not
valid politics it's not valid activism
it's not valid participation in the
political system and it has to be
stopped
now you will hear some say if we don't
tolerate tolerate other points of view
then we are as bad as them
um and uh that that's ridiculous
some are saying this in terms of trump's
permanent twitter ban which i'm going to
talk about later
it's just other opinions and we must be
tolerant it's the wrong perspective
we tolerate other opinions yes an armed
insurrection of the capital is not an
opinion it's a criminal travesty
it's anti-american it's anti-democratic
and when you tolerate
everything eventually the truly
intolerant come to power and destroy
society and the very tolerance you want
doesn't exist anymore
and it is you who who is being silenced
okay
this is where principles stop being
valuable in the abstract yes we are a
nation of tolerance
we tolerate other types of people we
tolerate other religions or no religion
whatsoever we tolerate ideology
we tolerate political ideas and dissent
and adversarial media yes all of it we
tolerate all of it but
you have to know how far that goes and
what we're seeing
doesn't have to be tolerated and it
shouldn't be understand that if we
tolerate what we've seen over the last
week
there will simply be more and more of it
until
they are in power and are completely
intolerant
toleration doesn't fix it toleration
doesn't
change minds so one option is that as i
said we as a country come together
against what we're seeing we recognize
that the country ceases to be a country
if this scoff law criminality and
revisionist history
and unhinged authoritarianism is
tolerated and that's going to be tough
for some people
i'm with you if you are a moderate
republican if you're in the vein of like
john mccain for example
it's going to be really tough to say wow
i'm a republican but that was bad and
it's it's unmitigated there's no ifs
ands or buts
it was a mistake we lost and now
we have to eliminate this malignancy and
joe biden is going to be president for a
while
democrats will have the house and senate
for a while that's tough to accept
even if you've been disgusted by trump
as a republican
so to those folks yes we need to be
tolerant and accept them
but we do not need to tolerate what led
to the armed mob last week
there's no planet on which that can be
tolerated we really are on a precipice
does this escalate even supposedly with
more planned planned riotous mobs in the
next 10 days
or do we actually come together and i
mean the left and the center and the
sane right
and law enforcement and our sane elected
officials the ones that are left and say
this can never happen again
and to stop that and uh uh
it's going to take years to fix but do
we start today or do we let them get
away with any aspect of it
we on the legal we must take swift legal
action against trump
and the terrorists and every state and
local republican member who supported
this
that's the best way to put a stop to
this movement there have to be
consequences
and one of the things i'm i'm sadly
seeing
are reactions from some of these
right-wingers saying you left it david
it sounds like you hate the country why
not leave or whatever
no no no no i'm an immigrant to this
country and i'm incredibly grateful to
this country
i want more people to get what i've
gotten
from this country and trump is the
opposite of that
if we allow what happened last week to
grow
and to fester we go the opposite of what
the united states
should be and and i know that this has
been said so many times
it's not patriotic to to just stand by a
politician
just because they're president we talked
about this when the right tried to say
you're not patriotic if you don't
support george w
bush's war in iraq no no no no that war
was bad for the country and so it's
patriotic to stand by what's best for
the country and i've warned against
deifying politicians by both the left
and the right
uh it is patriotic to stand up for
what's best for the country
even if it conflicts with your
partisanship so do not understate the
importance of this moment and we're
going to talk more about that
as we get closer and closer uh to the
inauguration of joe biden as president
a donald trump is going to be impeached
again uh there is every indication of
that and this is the right move and it
is actually
it has to happen and i'm going to to
make that case
uh for you today because number one when
impeachment is appropriate
you don't calculate you do it it is the
duty of congress to do it
and waiting even one more day is another
day that could be an absolute and total
disaster so the latest news from the new
york times this morning
is that the house of representatives
controlled by democrats is
moving to force donald trump out and
there it's sort of a
if you don't then we will scenario
speaker of the house nancy pelosi
says the house is going to formally call
on vice president mike pence to invoke
the 25th amendment
and strip trump of his power if they do
not
then the house is going to move to
impeach donald trump there is every
indication they have the votes
there is every indication it could
happen as soon as tomorrow
or wednesday now on the 25th amendment
the 25th amendment is this mechanism
by which the president along with a
majority of i'm sorry the vice president
along with a majority of the president's
cabinet can decide if the president is
unfit to serve
that they can remove the president the
president has the opportunity to
veto or reject that and in that case it
goes back to the house and senate
and i i now am blanking i believe you
need
two-thirds of the house and senate to
vote to override
the the decision of the president so
even if they pursued it
it's quite possible that it would not
succeed at removing trump
from every report we've gotten so far
mike pence uh does not have any interest
in moving forward on 25th amendment and
assuming that that is the case we have
already seen
drafted articles of impeachment again
for donald trump which would make him
the second
the first president ever to be impeached
for a second time
expectations are that debate in the
house would be relatively
uh short and concise and that donald
trump
within 48 hours very well could find
himself
impeached once again uh the
plan is that today and maybe by the time
you've heard this it will already have
happened
the house is going to move forward with
a resolution calling on pence to invoke
the 25th
and um in all likelihood that will go
nowhere and then tomorrow we would be
looking at
impeachment now there's a big debate now
and we're going to get into some of the
details of it later on what if this is
divisive
and it's so funny to hear these same
republicans who were involved in the
hang mike pence chance now saying no
we can't divide the country like this
the same republican lawmakers now
who for two months fomented and
perpetuated
these ridiculous notions that the
election was
stolen from donald trump through
conspiracies that involved everything
from replacement parts and voting
machines to hugo chavez
and some guy named eric coomer
they are saying it would be divisive to
impeach donald trump
there are others who are saying the
removal or impeachment of donald trump
at this
late stage would unnecessarily
inflame the same riotous mob that we saw
storm the capital last week
my view on this you all know that i
essentially uh um am always
thinking pragmatically and
in terms of principles and that i am
always
open to considering the practical impact
of something beyond just what it means
in principle
impeachments of presidents are such a
serious thing
um and when we think about
whether a president should be impeached
there is only one question that we ask
did the president do something worthy of
impeachment and if the answer is yes you
don't say well there's only 10 days left
you don't say well some of the right
wingers might get mad
it is the responsibility of the congress
to impeach when something impeachable
has taken place
even many republican defenders of donald
trump we'll play these clips for you
later
chris christie senator pat toomey
lisa murkowski even republicans now are
saying
this is a man that needs to be removed
and so
in this case we say we deal with the
consequences
if it is appropriate to impeach based on
the facts then we do it
and that's exactly what needs to happen
so later today
we will be having a live stream as these
deliberations get underway we are going
to be covering it all of this week that
is my position on impeachment it's
it's a it's a responsibility you don't
say well what might the impact be
if something impeachable has been done
you impeach let me know if you disagree
with me i'm on twitter at deepakman and
we're going to have
a much broader conversation about this
coming up the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25 percent off a subscription when you
go to
dot com slash david pakman i've put the
link
right underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that our program is mostly
funded by members who sign up
at joinpacman.com we have way too much
to talk about today for me to filibuster
for five minutes about membership but i
really do appreciate everybody who
signed up this month
and i encourage you to grab a membership
at joinpackman.com
um last week unfortunately and this
really is tragic
last week may actually not be the
craziest week of donald trump's
presidency it may be this week and what
is effectively the last eight or nine
days of donald trump's presidency
leading up to when next wednesday's
swearing in of president joe biden um
there are new reports out
about donald trump's plans for this week
and
uh it appears as though it is going to
be an absolutely
insane week from donald trump donald
trump of course now suspended
permanently
from twitter as we will talk about in a
little bit
uh donald trump after denouncing his own
vice president last wednesday at least
as of last night
hasn't even spoken to mike pence
and uh he is considering what can he do
in this last week and every possibility
is completely bonkers remember that
discussion
about a possible pardon in advance a
blanket pardon in advance of his own
family members it is increasingly
looking like donald trump is going to do
that
in the next eight or nine days maybe by
the time you listen to this clip some of
those pardons
will already have started there is still
the con consideration of donald trump
pardoning himself in fact and i know
that every time i talk about these
people right i didn't say a president
cannot pardon themselves
remember that we've gone into the
legality the legal scholarship on this
there are divergent opinions as to
whether a president can or cannot pardon
themselves but the most important thing
is it had
it has not been tested in court ever and
it is certainly
possible that a president can pardon
themselves and there is that
possibility as well trump absolutely
furious with twitter and other social
media
platforms for banning him either uh
temporarily
indefinitely or for life up to and
including twitter which we will talk
about
there is the idea that donald trump is
looking to do
something to big tech over the next uh
eight days that he has left nine days
that he has left in office we don't know
exactly what that will be
but it very well may be maybe absolutely
out of this world
and then donald trump also reportedly
planning to go
to the border in alamo texas in
in principle tomorrow tuesday to make a
big deal i guess out of his major
success
of building the wall i not that at this
point
i need to remind you but this is yet
another broken promise
fortunately it's a broken promise
because it was going to be a waste of
time and money to begin with
but donald trump promised that by the
end of his first term
we would have a wall between the u.s
mexico border on the u.s mexico border
across the entire border and of course
what we've seen
are modest improvements to a few and and
i'm using the term improvements
in terms of what they are called from a
construction standpoint um
modest improvements or renovations to a
few hundred miles of wall and that is
actually something donald trump has
promised and failed mexico didn't pay
for it trump didn't build the wall but
it's sort of a last
salvo he started by coming down the
escalator and telling us mexico's not
sending their best
they're sending uh the criminals and etc
um and it looks like we are sort of
coming full circle with donald trump
uh flying down to texas reportedly
tomorrow to claim
that he delivered on that that promise
as well
so there there are a number of different
um
what what to call there are a lot of
really bad arguments being made about
what should or shouldn't happen over the
next week and of course as we read about
the insane week that donald trump has
planned
my mind immediately goes to of course he
should be removed immediately by the
25th amendment but that requires
the cabinet and mike pence to act every
indication so far as we mentioned
earlier
is mike pence is not interested in doing
that so then
you have to realize that uh impeachment
must happen impeachment must happen and
the fact that we are seeing
some right wingers saying it would be
too divisive there are some on the right
and left saying
impeaching or removing trump would make
him a martyr
he's already both a deity and a martyr
to his own people the the committed
trumpist
sees trump almost like a god who can do
no wrong and say no wrong
and they already believe him to be a
martyr because as far as they see he's
been treated so unfairly by the
supposed fake news media he's been
treated so unfairly by the democrats and
all of this stuff
they are crazy and violent already they
are already
attacking violently as we saw last week
because trump lost the election and
neither he nor they can come to grips
with reality so
as i said earlier if removal is
warranted you must remove
if impeachment is warranted you must
impeach it doesn't appear as though
removal will happen so it must be
impeachment and as i said before taking
swift legal action against donald trump
and the insurrectionist riot riotous
terrorists
and every state and local republican
member who supported this
that is the best way to stop this
movement
the idea of it would be divisive to
impeach again
that doesn't stop the movement my
friends that's a failure it's nothing
it's not
it's not actually anything trump should
already be gone
and that's why i support another
impeachment which
uh we we discussed earlier waiting even
one more day
could spell disaster look at the
insanity of what he's planning over the
next week and then consider the urgency
of what's going on
so the big news that broke late friday
is that indeed
twitter has banned donald trump
permanently from its platform we're
going to go through the decision that
twitter made and then talk about the
implications
twitter putting out a statement saying
after a close review of recent tweets
from the trump account
and the context around them specifically
how they're being received and
interpreted on and off twitter
we have permanently suspended the
account due to the risk
of further incitement of violence in the
context of horrific events this week
we made it clear on wednesday that
additional violations of the twitter
rules
would potentially result in this very
course of action
our public interest framework exists to
enable the public to hear from elected
officials and world leaders directly
it is built on a principle that the
people have a right to hold power to the
account to account in the open
however we made it clear going back
years that these accounts are not above
our rules entirely
and cannot use twitter to incite
violence among other things
we will continue to be transparent
around our policies
and their enforcement now reportedly
when this happened
the word being used is ballistic trump
went ballistic
at the white house when he was banned
from twitter a senior administration
said that when twitter permanently took
down trump's account
um trump was scrambling trying to figure
out what to do
initially trump started tweeting through
the official potus account now the potus
account is an account that
is in the hands of whoever is president
so it's not trump's account it's it's
trump has access to it while being
president uh that has been shut down
trump then tried tweeting through one of
his aides or staffers
that was shut down and the president
reportedly
running around the white house going
absolutely crazy
this the white house then put out a
statement saying trump is negotiating
with other
sites and looking at building his own
platform and blah blah blah blah blah
so there's a there's a number of
different important things we have to
talk about here
first of all there's lots of really bad
arguments being made
by people on the right and people
on the left including that twitter
shouldn't be allowed to do this
either because they are silencing only
right-wing voices
which is untrue or because trump is
president of the united states
the uh guidelines are already a lower
bar
for world leaders twitter has said and
it was even implicit in the the
statement they put out
twitter has said that when one is a
world leader
they err on the side of not taking
content down and not banning
because they've determined and i agree
with their determination that it is
important for us to know what world
leaders are saying
uh however we would expect our elected
officials to be held to a higher
standard than the average twitter user
with two followers sending me hate
tweets right
like in other words it's
counterintuitive that
world leaders some of the most powerful
people in the world get held to an even
lower standard
merely because they are world leaders
that's been the case all along
twitter is a business that is allowed to
have terms of service and they're
allowed to enforce it
but consider the greater hypocrisy that
many on the right are now essentially
arguing
americans have an inalienable right to
be able to tweet any limitation on their
ability to tweet
is unconstitutional it's a violation of
rights granted by
you know god the constitution who knows
and by the way
there's no right to health care health
care is a product that should be bought
and sold on the free market if you can
afford it
but you cannot be restricted
in your ability to tweet give me a break
guys these people have been pathetic for
a very long time
don jr then coming out and saying whoa
we have to do something about the
market monopoly power of twitter
where are we on anti-trust well look at
your dad
uh i have been out there for years
saying
we are not and we've done multiple
interviews we are not dealing seriously
with the antitrust law that we have
and we have not enforced it i've been
talking about that for years
but all of a sudden the day trump's
banned from twitter
don jr cares about monopoly power give
me a break guys
so uh the the truth is trump's account
should have been
uh removed long ago there should be a
higher standard on elected officials not
a lower standard and trump
got away with it this long but now there
is sort of this deluge there's for lack
of a better term these massive dumps of
bans and suspensions that are coming now
since the riotous insurrection now a
cautionary message
despite my belief that this is the right
thing to do
based on trump's use of twitter and
incitements to violence and defense of
the rioters
despite the fact that we're saying it
was correct to ban
trump 12 days before he leaves office
forever
this is a sign of how much we've failed
as a country over the last four years to
control donald trump and to hold
accountable the people who defended him
the rats leaving the sinking ship now
betsy devos
william barr republican senator pat
toomey who now says trump should go
chris christie who now says trump should
be impeached
they are right yes sure but we're 12
11 10 now nine days out as they are
doing these things they do not deserve
to have their images rehabilitated
and we're going to talk about that after
the break but we will have more coverage
of the trump twitter ban and social
media implications
on our instagram where you can find us
at david pakman show
and you can find me on instagram as well
at david.pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world-famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at that's joinpacman.com p
a k m a n dot com if the normal prices
strike you as high by all means use the
coupon code
vote soon 18 all one word all lower case
become a member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
i mentioned at the top of the show in
our first segment sort of taking a big
picture look at what's going on and and
the the options the two possible paths
forward that the country is facing right
now
in the wake of the riotous insurrection
from last week i talked about what's
happening within the republican party
and you have some republicans that are
bailing on donald trump
uh and you have some that are not and i
made the point that
the the people that are bailing with 11
days to go
this is not an act of courage this is an
act of self-preservation and it's really
important that we not allow these people
to rehabilitate their reputations
because they've been part of it
for a very long time and only now when
it is relatively safe politically to do
so
they are saying this is too much that's
too much much i can't be a part of it
but that being said
there is a growing list of republicans
that now want to remove
donald trump and i think it's important
to understand that this is different we
did not see this
uh during the first impeachment as it
looks like we are heading towards a
second impeachment of the president so
let's talk about it a little bit
and go through some of the instances
republican senator lisa murkowski a
sitting
senator republican from the state of
alaska
says that she wants trump out and may
even leave the republican party
altogether over this now if she does
leave she's not saying she would become
a democrat
there's every indication that if she
were to leave the republican party she
would be an independent
but she put out a statement pointing out
that donald trump
incited this mob to unlawfully breach
the capital
led to injured and in fact uh law
enforcement
deaths uh put members of congress in
danger put the vice president in danger
interfered with the duty of congress to
count the electoral votes
and she goes on to say that donald trump
indeed should leave
lisa murkowski saying i think he should
leave he said he's not going to show up
he's not going to appear at the
inauguration he hasn't been focused on
what's going on with kovid
he's either been golfing or he's been
inside the oval office fuming and
throwing
every person who's been loyal and
faithful to him under the bus starting
with the vice president
he only wants to stay there for the
title she says he only wants to stay
there for his ego
he needs to get out he needs to do the
good thing but i don't think he's
capable of doing a good thing
so an important statement from
republican lisa murkowski
she's not saying she would vote to
convict she's saying trump should leave
trump should resign and it's not clear
that there's even a one percent chance
that he does that
um and yes she also went on to say
that uh the her future may not be in the
republican party but it's not in the
democratic party either
every indication is lisa murkowski would
become an independent if she were to
leave the party but it's something
it's still a big deal another current
republican senator pat toomey
says remove trump he's actually saying
it is time
to remove donald trump take a listen to
what he had to say yesterday on
one of the sunday shows your republican
colleague senator lisa murkowski of
alaska says president trump should
resign
she said uh quote he's caused enough
damage
do you agree yeah i do
uh i i think at this point with just a
few days left
it's um the best path forward the best
way to
get this person in the rearview mirror
uh for us
uh that could happen immediately i'm not
optimistic it will
but i do think that would be the best
way forward so that is a big deal
that it that that that is huge there's
no way around that
yes we're down to nine days left but
that is still uh uh
you know it's starting to point to what
we had you know when richard nixon
uh was about to be impeached republicans
got together and they went to him and
they said this is it
this is it you we you're getting
impeached and we're going to convict
um and at that time circumstances were
very different and it's
it's almost cliche and overly simplistic
to say republicans then were willing to
do what republicans today aren't willing
to do
the republican party is also
dramatically more radical today than it
was
um i think that today's republican party
also wouldn't have said to nixon it's
time to go
unfortunately uh but that was when there
was
something that was beyond the line today
nothing seems to be beyond the line for
most republicans so
good for pat toomey however he then says
in the same interview that
that voting for trump made sense at the
time after wednesday's attack you took
to the senate floor
to denounce president trump as a
demagogue but we should note you voted
for him in november for the second time
even after charlottesville right even
after he used force to clear
lafayette square for a photo op even
after he embraced q anon conspiracy
theorists many of whom were in that mob
i'm not saying you bear any
responsibility for what happened
on wednesday but do you regret not doing
more
to stop somebody you're now now calling
a demagogue
who's pretty obviously been a demagogue
for his entire political career
yeah jake i don't think there's any
doubt at all there's none in my mind
that the president's behavior after the
election was wildly different than his
behavior before he descended into a
level of madness
and engaged in activity that was just
absolutely unthinkable and unforgivable
for four years he often put out
offensive and objectionable tweets
actually sometimes dozens a day
i never felt and i still don't think
that my job was to be his
the editor of his twitter feed although
i was very often
critical so you can see the direction
that that's that's going
right i mean these are pathetic defenses
if we all knew
what the direction of trump's presidency
was going to be
why couldn't they know we knew in 2016
when trump was elected that this was
going to become an authoritarian
nightmare
and pat toomey says well you know other
than the mean tweets it all seemed
perfectly reasonable at the time no
and this is why i'm saying a lot of
these guys are doing this just out of
self-pressure preservation
and then lastly long-time trump loyalist
chris christie
says if inciting to insurrection
isn't impeachment worthy then i really
don't know what is
now but if an impeachment resolution
actually comes to the floor won't many
republicans be hard-pressed to oppose it
listen i think they're all going to have
to vote their conscience and
and look at what happened i mean what we
had was an incitement
um to riot at the united states capital
we had people killed
uh and to me there's not a whole lot of
question here
so you know so you think it was an
impeachable offense before jordan
oh sure yeah and and you'd vote to it i
think that
you know in the well that's if i think
it's an impeachable offense that's
exactly what i would do george but i'm
i'm not in there
but you want my opinion that's my
opinion i i don't i think if
if inciting to insurrection isn't then i
don't really know what is
um but i will say too that the democrats
by what they did earlier on ukraine
have kind of cheapened this a little bit
too so you know there
there's always a hedge and chris
christie says
democrats cheapened impeachment with
ukraine
but yeah he should be impeached this
time that's
a big time trump loyalist that's a
powerful republican figure
that's a guy who was metaphorically and
literally behind donald trump for years
standing on stage sometimes looking a
little sick from the
things trump was saying but it's a big
deal that chris christie now says yes
this is absolutely impeachable so
there's no sympathy for any of these
republican operatives they were behind
trump
for years but it is important that it's
also republicans this time too
not because we need to allow their image
to be rehabilitated
but because it confirms to us how bad
things are that even with the most
radical republican party we've arguably
ever had
we are starting to see some republicans
say it's time to go yeah it's pathetic
it's only nine days to go
i get it they don't get anything other
than
this does signal how insane the
situation has gotten but one guy
who i guess is going down with the ship
is republican senator lindsey graham and
i want to talk about him next
republican senator lindsey graham has
become one of the most
pernicious republican senators part of
why
he is so slippery is that lindsey graham
knows
how to every once in a while behave
sort of normally despite being mostly an
incompetent and dangerous
buffoon who sucks up to trump at every
opportunity and so
as an example last week lindsey graham
gave a speech during the late at night
when the count of the electoral vote had
resumed after the armed insurrection was
quelled
at least temporarily lindsey graham gave
a very reasonable sounding speech saying
listen
i supported this president and i wanted
him to win but
this strategy isn't going to work and
that strategy isn't going to work and in
the end the reason we're here
is mostly perfunctory and we have no
choice but to say joe biden is the next
president and a lot of people said oh
okay not bad golf clap
uh he's he's making some sense and
within just a couple of days of that
lindsey graham appears on fox news
begging for mercy for trump to avoid
being impeached or removed just
pathetic lindsey graham begging look at
this
i'm calling on vice president-elect
biden
to pick up the phone and call nancy
pelosi and the squad
to end the second impeachment president
trump gave a statement last night
that was helpful uh it hit the mark
he wants to move on to a peaceful
transfer of power he wants this to end
calling on biden to call nancy pelosi
what in just those first 20 seconds
lindsay is talking about uh
he's making statements riddled with lies
and distortions
he wants biden to call
pelosi the house of representatives must
determine if trump's behavior is worthy
of
impeachment if it is the house must
impeach
it's their responsibility and it is
their duty
i don't want nor need joe biden calling
nancy pelosi to influence her one way or
the other
if you said hey joe should call nancy to
encourage her to impeach no he shouldn't
no he shouldn't the decision on
impeachment is for the house of
representatives period
second you know lindsay says trump made
a helpful statement and committed to a
peaceful transfer
trump was essentially forced out there
to say the equivalent of now that i've
burned the whole house down i promise
not to light any more matches
and he did it under under duress excuse
me
and he didn't even mean it as evidenced
by the tweets that he sent immediately
after so 20 seconds
disgusting from lindsay let's look at
the end of what he had to say
i'm calling on vice president-elect
biden to pick up the phone
and call nancy pelosi and the squad to
end the second impeachment
president trump gave a statement last
night that was helpful
it hit the mark he wants to move on to a
peaceful transfer of power
he wants this to end i've been with him
most of the day he's going to focus on
his agenda
his successes for the american people in
the next few days but joe biden said
it's up to congress regarding
impeachment no president-elect biden
is up to you pick up the phone call
nancy pelosi chuck schumer and the squad
and tell them
stand down this will destroy the country
even further
you have the power to do that the
question is do you have the courage to
do it
joe biden was right it's up to congress
lindsay is a disgusting trump tool and
also by the way
again with the meme of this will be
divisive and it will further
destroy the country i'm sick of the
hypocrisy and this opportunist nonsense
from
from these people whenever they are the
ones causing the disunity they say
this is a time to come together we need
unity whenever
they are out of power and can't do any
anything as they will be
in just a few days they say well now we
need bipartisanship
whenever anger and wanting consequences
for actions turns against them because
of their radical behavior like last week
they caused us to get to this point and
now they say oh we need
calm and now that they've been as
divisive as anyone in history
in the united states they say oh
impeachment would be divisive
now impeachment's required the divisive
acts are the ones that warrant
impeachment when the facts say you must
impeach you must impeach
and and by the way had republican
senators like lindsey graham
voted to convict donald trump on
impeachment the first time
the riot never would have happened and
those
same republican senators now
think they get to tell us whether trump
should be impeached a second time it's
pathetic
lindsay constantly playing both sides
and and by the way
the sick irony of it failing lindsay has
been trying to play both sides for years
and he's been trying to do it over the
last uh four days as well
it failed lindsay sort of gave a mildly
reasonable speech on the floor of the
the uh house during that joint session
on uh on on what was it wednesday night
very early thursday morning
but then he still is begging for mercy
for trump and defending trump
but he was at the airport at the end of
last week getting ready to get on a
plane
and he had to have police protection
because the mega trumpist people
were screaming traitor traitor traitor
and surrounding
lindsey graham so it's so pathetic that
even his mealy-mouthed uh hypocrisy
and playing both sides has not spared
him the ire from the same riotous
insurrectionists
who stormed the capitol last week and it
it all has to end there are such
bigger issues here that need to be dealt
with in this country to really get this
insanity under control
uh widespread ignorance as a virus the
mind virus of ignorance and lack of
media literacy is part of the problem
um we will keep talking about the bigger
picture issues but what a pathetic clown
lindsey graham has really become the
david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
slash david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so i want to finalize our conversation
about uh donald trump getting impeached
a second time
as we've been filming the house has
started to move forward with what i
described earlier
an initial proposal for the 25th
amendment to be invoked every indication
that that is not going to happen and
then impeachment will be
subsequently the path forward we also
spoke earlier about how some republican
officials now say
that uh it's time for trump to go even
that he should be impeached we talked
about
pat toomey saying trump should leave we
talked about chris christie saying that
that
trump's inciting of the violent
insurrection is certainly impeachable
but where is the public on this that's
the next question and we do have new
polling on that according to a new
reuters
ipsos poll 57
of americans want donald trump to be
immediately removed from office this is
sort of like a
do not pass go did not collect 200 type
of thing and it is of course
directly related to his encouragement of
the protest
last week which escalated into a deadly
riot
inside the u.s capitol building most of
the people who want trump removed are
still democrats
republicans remain much more supportive
of donald trump
and uh seven out of ten of those who
voted for trump
in november oppose his removal
um but again when it's only 70 of
republicans who are against the removal
you end up with a situation where
led by democrats with many independents
and
some republicans the majority of the
country it's not
disapproves of the job trump is doing
it's
believes that donald trump should be
removed so there's a few
a different aspects to this one
yes it's notable that so many people in
the country want the president removed
but what's the other side of that it's
the same as what we've been saying when
we've looked at donald trump's approval
over the last four years
how is it this low in other words it
should be dramatically
more than slightly more than half of
americans
wanting the president removed the exact
number right now
is uh 57 percent when you blend
democrats independents and republicans
you end up with about 57 percent of
americans
wanting trump to leave office what about
the rest of them
and uh it's disappointingly low and i
think it's important to remember
you know we've talked today about this
idea that impeachment could be divisive
or
whatever the case and how i think those
are really bad arguments
i think there's another aspect to this
that's important to broach or to bring
up once again
impeachment is not about punishment
impeachment is what you do when the
facts
say that it's warranted and if the facts
say that it's warranted
it must be done and one of the reasons
i've seen
some be hesitant uh to support
impeachment
is they don't believe it would be a
sufficient punishment because trump is
leaving anyway
i think that that's both not the point
and also irrelevant because there is a
mechanism through which the senate can
vote
if the house impeaches the senate can
vote to convict
but they can also vote to strip trump of
the ability to run in the future and
that requires only a simple majority
and there are more things at stake there
is trump's million dollar a year
uh ex-presidential travel budget there
are other things that are at play here
so
for the folks saying the impeachment
wouldn't be a strict enough pun it
wouldn't really be much of a punishment
for trump at this point number one
i disagree in that being impeached
and if particularly if he was convicted
or stripped of the ability to run again
would be humiliating for donald trump
and that's a
it's quite a punishment when you
understand donald trump's psyche
there are also other things that would
be significantly deleterious to donald
trump's future but again
it is not about punishment trump's
mishandling of coronavirus
is impeachable uh trump's inciting of
this riot
is impeachable and if he did something
impeachable he must be impeached so
uh the i'm i'm tired of the it would be
divisive or it wouldn't be much of a
punishment mindset i'm also by the way
tired of the mindset
that we can just keep them under control
for the next however many days
it's not about that at this point in
time and it's not true
no one has been able to keep him under
control for any period of time i mean
look look at even last week
he incited the riot then he was
essentially from what we know
forced to go out there and say oh uh the
violence was bad
and there will be a transition like oh
wow he sounds slightly presidential
it was obviously disingenuous and within
hours he was back on twitter
repeating the same failed the the same
debunked
notions about um uh voter fraud and
75 million votes and all of this other
stuff so nobody can control him
it's not about that it's not about
punishment it's just what has to happen
and more than half of the country at
this point
believes that donald trump should be
immediately removed
we've been discussing for a long time
but in particular since the november
election
is there anything that could get a
really committed
trumpist to realize the error of their
ways
and to change their minds and to realize
that
they've been fueling the problem in
which the united states now
finds itself and i get many calls like
this
from viewers who say i don't know how to
talk to my aunt
or my significant other or my parents or
whoever else
and it's a very difficult thing and my
advice is usually pretty general in
nature
but it can happen at least in theory
a supposed uh a supposed trumpist
called c-span in tears apparently
realizing or at least suspecting
that she had been lied to by donald
trump and
uh she goes by tammy in boise idaho
this could be fake we don't know i mean
it's impossible to really know this
could be some kind of troll but
it certainly appears to be real take a
listen to tammy from idaho in tears
as she realizes trump
may have lied to her what are your
thoughts about today i just have one
question
i wanted to know if my president lied to
me today
and if he did i want me him to tell me
and more importantly
i want him to tell the family of the
woman that
got shot and killed today i voted for
him
i voted for him
and sorry
that's tammy and boise so there are many
reasons to be curious about whether
this is legit you and i might be saying
how could
anyone doubt trump has been lying all
along obviously he's been lying all
along
but the reality is that tens of millions
don't realize
or haven't yet realized that donald
trump has been lying about everything
all along including over the last two
months
acutely so about supposed voter fraud
but
assuming that this caller is genuine and
that this is someone starting to see how
they've fallen for it
understand that they've been bamboozled
not just by trump
but they've all also been bamboozled by
fox news
and the other right-wing media and and
that apparatus
and by other republicans as well so if
this is real
i get all of these calls where people
say how do i talk to these people how do
i change their minds
if and when people reach the moment that
tammy reached
this is when we talk to them about
coming back to reality this is the
opportunity if
if anyone you know is fortunate enough
to reach a moment like tammy appears to
have reached
that's when you swoop in and say yes
he's been lying
i'm so glad you see it come on back
let's figure it out and work together to
prevent it from happening again
you don't go you idiot of course that's
what's been going on now
we're all thinking it and you know in a
platform like this to some degree it's
like of course you fools
how did you not know it but for
everybody who's been asking me
how do you do it what do you do on a
personal level what do you do when the
opportunity presents itself you say
welcome back he lied to he lied to all
of us
let's never let this happen again and
most people aren't ready to accept this
most of you aren't going to get someone
at tami's stage of realizing
what has happened i don't know how you
force it i don't know that you can
i think there's something sort of about
one's predisposition and constitution
whether you just in the face of
contradictory evidence you double down
and double down and double down
uh and some folks are more predisposed
to hear reason
maybe hearing from republicans that they
trust
or used to trust like you know mitt
romney arnold schwarzenegger had a great
video that he put up over the weekend
chris christie has now bailed maybe they
are going to help turn some of these
folks
back to reality and make them ready to
understand how they've been bamboozled i
don't know
and so understand that this is not about
empathizing with these people
necessarily they have been part of one
of the most toxic
political movements in the history of
the united states tens of millions of
them are nowhere near ready to abandon
it like tammy is
don't concern yourself with forgiveness
or empathy
the evidence of trump's lies has been
there forever
i know it you know it but if we can get
them back then we should do it it should
be approached from a pragmatic
standpoint and one of the real lessons
of trumpism
has been how easy it is to fool massive
groups of people
we knew it in cults for example the jim
jones
people's temple but that was 900 people
who went to guyana and ultimately drank
the arsenic-laced kool-aid but here
we're talking about
tens of millions of people and we've
seen the bamboozling
at minimum and i spoke about this uh uh
or i will speak about it with peter
joseph who we're going to be
interviewing
we've seen it since the reagan era the
non-existent
welfare queen uh who's hanging around
uh um driving a cadillac i think it is
um as she pops out kids to make great
profits from food stamps and welfare
benefits
it was non-existent then and it's built
and built and built and the last four
years have confirmed that yeah it's
possible to fool
way more people about way more obviously
untrue things so there are lessons here
about
cults there are lessons here about mass
brainwashing
a lot of this is mental health as well
but it's not
right or or proper to say these are just
crazy people but there's a mental health
component here as well
we've learned about how ignorance can be
quite literally weaponized
if you don't believe i mean listen okay
there's people out there who just have
bloodlust and even if they don't believe
the election was stolen they hear trump
saying let's go to the capitol
they say great it's an opportunity to to
get involved in violence okay
the vast majority of these folks though
if they don't fall for it was stolen
they're not going to go to the capitol
in riot
because it because someone is saying
that it was stolen in other words the
the ignorance and the disinformation
that has been promulgated and
perpetuated by trump and the people
around him
was literally weaponized into a riot
that's the the way we have to understand
that and so
tammy if this is legit good for her i
know that there are anecdotal stories
from people in my audience of similar
things that have happened but
i think that as much as we would like
everybody to have an awakening like
tammy did and sort of
be open to being being given some some
reality some facts
uh if it took 40 years to get into this
we're talking about you know at least
a decade of significant working towards
social change eight to ten years and
it's not realistic to imagine that in an
in a democracy or something at least
approximating one
uh that type of change is going to
happen really quickly it's just not if
it takes a long time to get in it's
going to take some time to get out
hey we had um we had some insanely long
live streams last week
because of the armed insurrection and we
got a great call
on our voicemail number which is 219 to
david p
uh just a very nice person saying thanks
for
for the live streams thanks for the long
days take a listen
hi this message is for mr pacman this is
ambrosia i wanted to just let you know
that you did an
outstanding job yesterday january 6th
uh with your live streams you were
streaming for like six or seven
hours and um
it's crazy because your commentary made
sense
you didn't wear out you tapped out for a
little bit and then you came back i mean
it was better than any um mainstream
media news outlet
um coverage that i saw i
got most if not all of my information
from your live stream so i just wanted
to say
you did an outstanding job you did
and my props to you and
lots of love from texas and we don't we
do not playing ted cruz we don't
okay thanks mr paxman all right there it
is a beautiful message i i really do
appreciate it we
we had uh yeah so on i mean on the sixth
as we watched what we thought would be a
very boring but long
many hours of debate over objections to
counting ballots we saw the armed
insurrection
uh grow before our very eyes
and they were very long days i really
appreciate hearing from folks who who
appreciated
um us us being with you and uh it was a
privilege
to be with everybody who joined those
streams and we're going to continue
covering
unfortunately i hate to say it but i
believe that there will be more to cover
in the next week and of course we will
be with you on january 20th for the
inauguration and swearing-in
of president joseph r biden jr so much
much to come and of course the streams
are live
we're typically live on three platforms
youtube
which is youtube.com the david pakman
show twitch twitch.tv
davidpakman and facebook facebook.com
davidpakmanshow so i will see you but
before that uh we do have a great bonus
show for you today
senator joe manchin has a different view
about stimulus checks
already it didn't take long my friend so
we will you know the idea of
is joe manchin going to be okay with
this it's not just a meme it's not just
a mere
hypothetical it immediately has an
impact we'll also talk about the biden
administration's
different approach on vaccine doses
really
important topic and we will also talk
about a west virginia republican state
lawmaker
who has resigned after being allegedly
involved in the
riotous storming of the u.s capitol so
we will have
all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show as i will be
joined by producer pat
you can sign up and get instant access
at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman